everyone repeat after me I don't consent
to searches hi I'm Jim Cavanaugh a
reason TV we're here with steve
Silverman executive director of flexi
rights org Steve can you tell us a
little bit about what flex your rights
or gives permission is to educate people
about how to assert their constitutional
rights during police encounters and the
way we get this information out is
through the website but primarily
through our know your rights videos what
are the products that you guys put out
two DVDs our first one was busted the
citizens guide to surviving police
encounters at least in 2003 that sort of
our countercultural favorite what you
got there mark Wow look at this
smells fresh and our most recent one is
ten rules for dealing with police now
those of you who don't know me I'm Billy
Murphy and we're gonna talk about how to
deal with the police that was released
March of 2003 a rather my mistake 2010
okay one of the things that's haven't
taken any drugs before this interview I
I drank some caffeine so little jittery
but thanks for asking how about you say
am i into being detained or am I free to
go when you're saying no to the police
even if you're doing so civilly and but
when you you pull the tricks out and you
say I don't consent to a search am I
free to go or am I being detained which
is has a lot actually you want to talk
about that a little bit I would argue
that you know asserting your
constitutional rights is not it's not a
trick in any way what the police
officers do is the trick where one of
the important things to appreciate is
that police officers are legally allowed
to lie to you and say things like we're
just searching for bombs we're not
looking for anything else that's
generally a lie and police are legally
allowed to lie we've had some problems
with gangs moving guns down this highway
not packing any tec-9 sorry no sir I
didn't think so so you don't mind if I
take a look do you just to clarify on
that if you if the cop says we're
looking for bombs and you say okay we'll
go ahead and search then they find pot
you don't have any protection then right
because you've consented to the search
and and it's you know you don't have any
sort of Fourth Amendment
absolutely.you you have no expectation
of privacy at that's that point if you
consent what we teach is that it is
actually your choice and when an officer
asks you don't mind if I take a look
they use a command present to command
voice it sounds a lot like command you
want any drugs in here
no you know my if I take a look then
what if I say no
Darryl Borden I want you to listen to me
very closely you have two choices you
can either make things better or you can
make things worse for yourself they're
not so much trained to do that but they
learn to do that on the job pretty
quickly if you ask an officer how to get
people to consent to these searches
they'll just tell you
well everyone just you know they agree
to be searched and it's sort of like
really you know what's going on there
during traffic stops which are about 50%
of all police encounters that you're
likely to see police have to search nine
to ten people in order to find evidence
of illegal activity on one and so you
ask an officer a good officer you see
like why would you search so many people
in order to find illegal activity on one
but humiliate everybody else to this
search say well people are willingly
cooperating I'm sure you know there's
been some gang-related shootings in the
neighborhood mm-hmm well we're trying to
do something to get the guns off the
streets and we're asking folks to help
out of course how can I help
well if you don't mind we'll take a
quick look around to make sure there is
no guns in your home you might not know
about there no guns in here go ahead you
know I don't know if that is so much or
really like active willing compliance
but sort of like an ancient groveling
response in the face of authority that's
what I was thinking about earlier it's
sort of a natural reaction on P
especially you know I Wimpy Epsilon male
like myself if the cop is saying uh you
know do you need consent to a search of
course I don't want to make him angry at
me and you know I want to be look like
I'm a good citizen and maybe the cop
will become my friend is it a really an
emotional barrier that you have to get
people over it really takes a certain
amount of training in a sense the videos
are training videos are the main reasons
that we started getting into videos I
actually used to like Don a police
officer cap and do like role-playing
exercise
stuff like that but the stuff just
doesn't really stick unless you're able
to actually either do role-playing or
see people that you can relate to in
these situations doing it wrong and then
doing it correctly are you detaining us
officer or are we free to go now mr.
Borden can I see your car keys please
why need to give you a car look to make
sure you don't have anything you're not
supposed to have you don't have anything
to hide do you no officer I don't
consent to any searches sir we all know
if the man gets off on harsh in your
mellow and is the right way to respond
to that to say up yours baby I'm power
to the people
well that none but it is of course your
choice how you refer to police in Canada
it's always your choice what we're
trying to offer here are different
options every day we're exposed to some
really horrific cases of police
misconduct police abuse you know
bloggers like Radley Balko Carlos Miller
just do an outstanding job of just
chronicling these and justices not only
the individual injustice but also the
endemic lack of accountability that
occurs after them and so we've seen the
police shooting the dog video
you know the grandmother being tasered
what can happen from you know watching
this every day one of the unintended
consequences it can actually really
cloud the view of what a typical police
encounter is likely to look like and so
if you're someone who exposes yourself
to these horrors and every day you know
online it can lead to someone really
deciding to blow up at the point of a
police encounter which is absolutely the
worst time to do that and in fact when
we released 10 rules for dealing with
police I thought the most articulate
criticism that we got specifically
focused on what we created as rule
number one which is always be calm and
cool at the point of a police encounter
we're sort of accused of seeming to be
kowtow into police even worse than that
some folks suggested that we essentially
were blaming the victim hold up are you
saying that he deserved to get treated
like that no what I'm saying is a police
encounter is absolutely the worst time
and place to vent your
frustrations about police getting
stopped by police is always frustrating
and scary but you could have played it
much smarter by being calm and cool
what's the difference between blaming
the victim and treating the person who
is subjected to the police encounter as
an active agent who can has some effect
on the outcome of the encounter that
really gets to the heart of what our
message is the decisions that you make
can have a massive impact on the course
of that encounter and the ultimate
outcomes that encounter be it whether
you could prevent a search from
happening in the first place or simply
driving away or if you are the victim of
police misconduct despite being calm and
actively asserting your constitutional
rights you will be in a far superior
position in the legal sense if you
choose to pursue a policeman's conduct
complaint if you were calm during the
course of that encounter rather than
having a police video showing you
screaming at the top of your head the
you're likely to create much better
outcomes for yourself at the point of
that encounter so that's what we really
really press the idea of always be calm
and cool although it's always your
choice how you want to behave with a cop
the smart move is always to say I do not
consent to a search the Fourth Amendment
the Bill of Rights is not just some ball
and chain around a policeman's ankle to
keep them from finding the bad guys the
Bill of Rights is actually I would argue
a template for good policing it requires
officers to actually have evidence to
search someone so they're not wasting
their time spreading large nets using
crude techniques like racial profiling
to go into one single area in search
everyone and so for the person who has
nothing to hide I think an officer
should feel a sense of embarrassment
asking someone to consent to a search
when they otherwise have no actual
probable cause to search someone a
citizen I think should be offended at
their questions should not let the
police officer trick them into thinking
that in any way they're helping law
enforcement if you have nothing to hide
you in no way are helping law
enforcement do their job so it's
important to test whether or not that
officer is going to respect your
constitutional rights and if you refuse
and they
search you you ought to file police
misconduct report too and take that as
far as you legally can
[Music]